dans un bon soir une chanson convention
avec alain bellemare on comprend qu
alain bellemare et congés dits oui
monsieur bellemare évidemment avait
embauché en février mars 2015 pour
transformer transport et bombardier
et beaucoup d'observateurs s'attendaient
à ce que monsieur bel mal arrive dans
les usines
il a améliore la productivité on savait
que le management de bombardier est un
peu léger il manquait de rigueur y
manquait de deux disciplines
donc on s'attendait à ce que monsieur
bellemare arrive à fort de son
expérience de protée nous était une
technologie arrive et mettre de l'ordre
dans les filiales redresse les
entreprises donc on saturday ce que
quelqu'un est dans les usines avec les
vices et les écrous note cndd aux
échanges la performance des compagnies
mais ce n'est pas monsieur bellemare
était resté le super pussy en surface ce
qu'il a fait c'est qu'ils leur être ici
la compagnie il devra en du 60 et 10%
des actifs durant cinq ans aucun des
secteurs n'a été vraiment redressées et
s'était plutôt une liquidation du genre
et lui dit qu'il est fier de ce qui
s'est passé qui l'a sauvé l'entreprise
et sauver des emplois
c'est quoi le message du conseil
d'administration en changeant pdg ben
c'est que monsieur bellemare peut être
effectivement sauver des emplois
mais est-ce que son plein transformation
est terminée on s'est dit là il ne reste
plus qu'une chose à transformer ces les
avions d'affaires
orlan aussi dit monsieur bellemare a été
l'homme d'une situation pour améliorer
la compagnon il y aurait pu la redresser
mais le liquide et il le liquide est en
bonne partie ce cas le conseil belle
conseil étaient d'accord avec avec
cécile ont donné leur aval à ces
différentes en aiguille on n'y avait pas
beaucoup de choix
la famille beaudoin déçu de sauf pensée
by la famille beaudoin et des sudokus du
travail de monsieur bel bat en ce sens
que monsieur bellemare ne pas livrer le
redressement que l'on s'attendait de lui
il n'a gardé il vit
videz l'entreprise de la plupart de ces
opérations
et là il ne restait que les avions
d'affaires donc et puis le titre comme
vous l'avez mentionné les plus de 2
dollars
donkey 64 cents aujourd'hui c'est
presque plus rien donc il ne reste que
les avions d'affaires
et là on n'a plus besoin de
transformateurs d'un transformateur
là ça va prendre un opérateur quelqu'un
qui va avoir les deux mains sur le
volant et qui va aller voir vraiment les
avions d'affaires
comment est ce qu'on peut améliorer la
productivité et les les ventes et éric
martel est la bonne personne pour ça
éric martel c'est un c'est quelqu'un que
tu leur vrai dans les multinationales
il était chez procter gamble ronceraille
chez kraft foods 13 ans chez bombe at il
à peu près tout fait chier bon parti
donc il a terminé le jeu responsable les
avions d'affaires donc et il quittait il
obtient au moment de l'arrivée de
monsieur bellemare s'était notoire
bombardier que monsieur bellemare et
monsieur martel ce n'était pas du tout
le grand amour et l trois mois après
l'arrivée de monsieur bellemare
monsieur martel qui tu es là évidemment
monsieur bellman la peau du tournis donc
il est allé pour hydro-québec donc
monsieur martel chez hydro québec il a
bien fait ça y avait des surplus
d'électricité
avant lille mis en place une stratégie
il essayait de liquider ses surplus là
en nouvelle angleterre il a fait un bon
travail je passe le gouvernement était
prêt à renouveler son mandat
oui mais quand on est un travail qui se
fait chez hydro-québec une stratégie et
un désir de de développement par exemple
sont nés sur les exportations et c est
ce qu éric martel ne part pas trop vite
au milieu de quelque chose mais on ne
peut pas raisonner division évidemment
la rémunération brute la rémunération de
sumac terre elle va elle va se
multiplier par rapport aux 5 600 milles
diderot qu'ils mèneraient hydro québec
qui va passer à quoi 13 14 millions chez
bombardier peut-être moins qu'il y aura
un peu moins que monsieur bellemare
évidemment pian plus moussu bellemare
n'a pas été très appréciée parce que il
a vendu ses actions à 4 dollars une
bonne partie des actions alors que le
titre
ferme soit et casse aujourd'hui donc
monsieur bart elle arrive et là il va
focus et sur les avions d'affaires et
c'est un bon opérateur c'est quelqu'un
qui va être capable de focus et sur ce
qui reste de bombardier et je pense que
pour lui pour sa carrière pour ses
aspirations
le milieu de travail qu'il aime c'est
l'international là évidemment avec
hydro-québec qui travaillait surtout en
nouvelle angleterre et au québec
donc dans ce contexte là pour monsieur
martel c'était un nouveau défi de
revenir de devenir finalement le grand
patron de bombardier est donc ça nous
dit quoi sur l'avenir d'hydro-québec à
partir de maintenant elle vient hydro
québec parce que l'onf allons trouver un
nouveau pdg
il faudra trouver un nouveau pdg une
nouvelle stratégie hydro québec qui veut
avec le fournisseur d'énergie propre de
l'est de l'amérique
c'est un programme ambitieux il ya le
terre-neuve qui est très mal en point
avec bosquette ford
donc il ya beaucoup d'enjeux importants
à hydro-québec et là le choix du
prochain président on ne trouve
quelqu'un à la caisse de dépôt le grand
commis de l'état c'est celui de au
québec prochain président au prochain
président ou prochaine présidente
il est tout à fait possible mais les
défis pour hydro québec sont très
importants hydro québec est le principal
pourvoyeur de fonds 2 milliards de
dividendes ou au de plus au gouvernement
du québec dont d'âge contexte là surtout
à l'asra pour monsieur legault c'est
extrêmement important probablement va
regarder d'abord à l'interné ce soit
pour poursuivre aimant la stratégie
michel nadeau merci à bien merci pour
cette analyse ce soir